The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, so let's
go ahead and get started.
A couple quick announcements
before we jump into the day.
We had a couple
questions about what
happens if one of
my team members
dropped out of the class
for this first project?
Has anybody had that?
OK, so if somebody
drops out of your team
at any point in next first
two projects, that's OK.
You're not going to be penalized
for having fewer people.
You're not going to be propped
It's basically we're
not necessarily
grading the quality of the
games for this first project
right now.
Double check the
project one assignment
to see what the grading
rubric is for that.
What we are checking is
are you doing iteration?
Have you tested the
game multiple times?
Do you have multiple
versions of the game?
So that's basically reflected
in your design change log
that you're doing
for this class.
There's also an
individual write up.
So we're asking you
to write a one page
paper about your experience
with the requirements for that
are in the assignment.
We want to know what happened
when your teammate dropped out.
Did it feel different?
If you had two people
versus three people,
do you feel like
you had fewer ideas?
That's actually a really
interesting thing for you
to understand about.
When you're coming together
and working on group projects
and you're doing
collaborative projects,
what does team size do to
the kind of ideas you have,
the number of ideas you have,
and the quality of ideas
you have?
In all the later
projects, your team
is going to be big enough
that dropping one member
isn't going to be
huge difference.
Dropping two might.
So if that happens, just
let us know about it.
We'll talk you through it.
It'll be OK.
We'll get through it.
ANDREW GRANT: If I
may, this is actually
part of the experience
of working on a team.
Sometimes you lose people, and
sometimes that's a problem.
I like to call it the
hit by a bus test.
If your team can't stand losing
one person-- any one person--
then you have to plan
around that and make sure
you can handle it.
Other people like to call
it the winning the lottery
test because that's nicer,
but basically one person
gets taken out of equation.
You do have to adapt to that
and be ready for it to happen.
Again, on this project, it's
a relatively-- the teamwork
is easier, because it's
a simpler deliverable
and a simpler project.
PROFESSOR: But things
are going to come up
throughout the semester--
somebody falling sick,
somebody going away
for interviews,
especially seniors going
for job interviews.
Those are things
you're going to plan
for to react to and have
alternate plans, just in case
something like that
happens during the project.
So just be aware of that
throughout the class.
So what are we doing today?
Today's a very,
very busy day that's
going to involve lots of
movement on your part.
We're going to do a
workshop on version control
that Drew is going
to walk you through.
We're going to go
into discussion groups
and talk about the
game engine tutorials
that you all completed
before today,
and they'll be a mechanism
for talking about that.
Basically people talking
about forming groups
in the same project and then
later on forming groups where
we can have people
compare-- somebody
who worked on Unity talking to
somebody who worked on Flixel.
Things like that.
After that, we're going to
have project one play test.
So this is going to be
an informal play test.
Basically it's a check.
Can you play your game today?
If you can't, then
play what you've
got, because you're going
to be forced to play it.
Maybe you have some
rules written down.
Great.
Just act them out in that
15 minute block we give
you to act out those rules.
And maybe within
that 15 minute block,
come up with a few
different rules
or a few different pieces.
So that's going to
happen, and we'll
go through how that's
going to work later.
And then at the end
of the day, we're
going to do another workshop.
Sara is going to lead
us on that-- talking
about vision statements.
So this is a tool
that we use to help
large teams understand what
it is we're actually creating.
So with that I'm going to
switch slides and bring it over
to drew.
ANDREW GRANT: So
the first thing, I
see a lot of laptops,
which is pretty awesome.
How many of you
brought a computer
that actually has the code you
used for you tutorials on it?
That is more than half.
Awesome.
So you get the short version of
presentation, not the long one,
as soon as we get it
up there and going.
Let's see.
Any other questions?
Who here has used version
control or source control
before.
Most of you.
Fascinating.
Who here feels
confident that you
know why you used
version control,
and that it was awesome,
and you're cool,
and you're good at this?
OK, the hands went
up and started
to come down slowly,
which would make sense.
That's what they
should have done.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, so I'm
not actually going
to talk about the nitty gritty
details of exactly which
commands you type,
because there's
a bunch different
version control systems.
They all work very
similarly, but you're
going to basically need
to read the documentation
on the particular one
that you're using.
I recommend today, if
you're familiar with one,
that you stick with
that if possible,
but don't worry about
it if you can't.
So let's see.
I'm going to give a
high level description
of what is revision control.
I'm going to use
different words for it.
Source control, revision
control are the big ones.
The basic notion is that-- and
this is a very simple notion--
that you've got one copy of the
source on your local machine,
and you've got one copy of
the source somewhere else,
and that copy out there
is the perfect copy.
That's the true copy of
what you're working on.
That's the platonic
ideal of your project,
and your job is to copy
files down from it,
change them, and copy
them back up to that one.
Not much going on there, right?
All right.
I'll get into more
details on that.
So we started with a
whole bunch of words
that go along with this topic.
Revision control system, RCS,
is often used as a generic term.
It's also a specific
piece of software
that you probably won't use
because it's really old.
Source control, revision
control, and you'll
also see SCM as a common TLA
for source control management.
CVS, the concurrent version
system, is also older,
but one you might
actually see used.
It's mostly command line only.
SVN is a more recent open
source version of CVS.
I think CVS may have been, too.
I'm not sure on that one.
SVN is more usable, and
I highly recommend it.
Perforce is one that's used
quite often in the games
industry, and then
you're going to see
Git and Mercurial,
which are often
mentioned in the same breath.
They're both what's called
distributed source control.
We'll get to that, but
they're interface is
very similar to all
of the above actually.
Almost all have a command
line interface where
you can do it everything from
command line, and most of them
have a GUI that you
can use as well,
but you're going to see a
bunch of different words used
to talk about the stuff.
So again, in its most basic
form, you've got a server.
You've got your local.
You copy stuff back and forth.
Pretty basic.
And it's a little bit easier
to see why you might want that
when you've got more than
one person on the team.
It's a really good way to
make sure your files are
synchronized.
It's even more important
the bigger your team.
So what's really,
really important
is that that server copy
of your code is useful.
So you want to make
sure that you are only
contributing to that
central repository of code
the useful pieces.
Now, what we really
want to do is
that central version
of the code is
sort of what's considered,
as I mentioned,
ideal version of your code.
It's authoritative.
It's the one you can trust.
So that actually becomes
a little bit more
than a backup system, right?
So a backup system
is quite useful.
If you lose something
or you make a mistake,
you want to be able to
revert to a previous version
of your code, and that is
certainly one of the things
that source control
does for you.
And we'll also talk about how
it's a way to share your code,
but it's actually more
important than that.
So the history of
your project is
one of the big things
you get out of it.
When you submit your files,
which can be source code
file-- it could be images.
It could be anything.
When you submit them,
you should include
a comment about what
the heck you've done.
And this is one of the things
I find new programmers have
the hardest time with.
In fact, I know plenty of old
programmers that can't do it,
but really it's useful,
and the reason it's useful
is all because of this.
We're going to talk
about different methods
of communication
throughout this course,
and I've talked about-- or
I will talk about the fact
that your source code
is a way to communicate
with other people.
But it turns out your comment
log in your version control
system is also great way to
communicate with your team.
So for example, if you
submit a whole bunch of files
and it's not obvious what
that did to your game,
that comment can tell
everyone else on your team
what just happened.
Maybe you rewrote the entire
AI so that the bad guys now
run away from the player.
And it may be that
someone else on your team
is trying to figure out why are
the bad guys' AI broken now?
And the answer is
it's not broken.
They're just doing
something different.
And when they do get that
code from the server,
they're going to see that
comment and say, oh, I get it.
The AI changed.
So if you fail to report
that in a Scrum-- or maybe
you don't have a Scrum
because you did it
in the middle of
the night-- this
is a great way to
communicate with your team.
Even more than that, that
history is also really useful.
Let's say you check
in this code that
causes bad guys to run away,
and then a couple days later you
find out that there's
some problem in the AI
where things actually crash
horribly if the game sits there
for an hour.
Well, where do you begin
looking for that bug?
You may not know
that it's in the AI.
You may just have
some clues, but you
know that it changed
in the last two days.
This behavior started.
So you can look at
the log and say,
what happened in
the last two days?
And someone further
discovers that, well, it's
crashing somewhere in AI.
Then you can have a hint
that it's in the AI system,
but more than that, you go to
the exact last change in the AI
system and look at those
files, and that's probably
where your bug is.
That's pretty handy.
And let's say that you do
something really, really
horrible.
You also get an undo
button out of this.
You can say, you know what?
That version two days ago--
let's go back to that.
That's better than
what we have right now.
You don't often do that,
but it is really nice
to have that kind of security,
especially when you're
working in your local version.
Let's say you're
trying to find a bug.
You need to change 15 files, and
putting into debug statements
everywhere to figure out
what the heck's going on.
And then you find
the bug finally,
and you realize it's
a one line change.
Well, it's easier just to revert
back to the server version
and make that one line
change than to make sure you
undo every little piece.
Let the computer be your memory.
Let the computer be
your undo button.
You don't need to
rely on knowing
which files you changed.
It will tell you.
And this is the cool thing that
is kind of scary, but pretty
awesome-- is you can
actually simultaneously edit
the same files if
they are text files.
This involves a merge
process afterwards
which is a little
bit frightening
the first several
times you do it,
but actually the
tools are pretty good.
As long as you're not modifying
the same line of the file,
it's pretty good about figuring
what should happen, but you do
need to manually check
it with your eyes
to verify it didn't
do anything stupid,
but it's actually
pretty common to work
to be able to work with
same file with two people
and actually have
it work out OK.
The exception to that is
extremely complicated text
files or binary files--
you can't merge changes
to a PNG of GIF.
That doesn't make sense,
at least on the file level.
And a lot of the
data files in Unity,
especially the scene
files and prefab files,
are going to be too
complicated probably
for you to actually
manage to emerge.
So for those, you need
to be a little bit more
careful about it, but it's
actually a really useful tool
to lean on that.
So we're going to talk about
the various operations very,
very quickly.
When you copy things
from the server,
different source control systems
will call it different things.
You're going to see the term
get to mean pull the files down
from the server.
Update, pull, and checkout
in different systems
will mean that same thing--
copy files from the server.
I also have in there
the word revert,
which is kind of a
fancy special case.
When I said you can
undo your changes--
you've got a whole
bunch of files changed,
and you don't like
those changes--
you can revert to the
server version, which
is-- under the covers, what's
really going on there is you're
copying down from the
server, but you'll
call that revert because
it's going to ask you,
wait a minute, you
changed that file.
Are you sure you really
want to wipe that out?
And at that point, you
should say yes or no
depending on how sure
you are that you really
want to do that.
Similarly, when you
have decided that you've
finished with your
changes locally
and you want to copy them out
to the server for everyone else
to see, that's going to be
called submit, commit, put,
push or check in.
Generally speaking, people
talk about that copying up
to the server directionally.
The reason they use some
fancy words like commit
is that they want you to
realize that this is not-- I'm
just copying a file.
You're copying a file
for everyone to see.
So you want to ensure that
your changes are good.
This one's easier.
If you want to find out the
status of what's going on,
almost all the source controls
use the word status for that.
But basically what you can do
is you can say things like,
so I've changed
a bunch of files,
and I forget what I've changed.
I'm sure there's a lot of them.
You can actually ask your
source control system,
what did I change?
And it'll say, well, these
five files have changed,
and in fact, you can even get
more information from that
if you want to compare what
those actual changes are.
And diff is the term for that.
Locking files so no one else can
change them is not often used
in source code, but
it's very useful
for-- as I was
talking about, there
are some files that are so
complicated that it can't
automatically
merge them for you,
and the binary files as well.
You may find that some
source control systems don't
automatically lock these for
you, and so in that case,
you might want to make
as your team policy
that you want to lock the file
so that no one else messes
with it.
So again, I'll go back
to Unity as an example.
If you're changing the main
scene file for your game
and it's this complicated
gigantic XML thing,
you might lock that file
so no one else changes it
while you're working on it.
And then finally, merge is
the last thing that you'll do.
And I talk about, if you're
changing one code file
and someone else changes a code
file while you're working on it
and checks it in
before you do, you're
going to include their
changes into your version,
and that's called a merge.
Most of them have tools that
do it for you automatically,
but if there's a
conflict, it will then
force you to do what's called
a resolve, which is to say,
hey, this file changed more
than I could figure out
automatically, so a human
needs to interfere with it,
and that point--
that's called resolve.
And that's what the
process is called, too.
You'll have to go through
that manually a couple times.
So we talked about how this
is an authoritative server,
and that's true for
Perforce And Subversion.
And basically there's
the one server
that's going to be
taking care of you,
but it's not always true,
especially if you're
looking at Git and
Mercurial, which
use what's called
distributed source control.
There actually is no
difference between your version
of the code, and the
servers version of the code,
or your teammates
version of the code.
It's just a bunch
of lists of changes,
and you can send
them left, and right,
and upwards, and downwards.
It doesn't matter.
But if you actually
do this, you're
in trouble, unless you're
really careful about it.
So whenever you do
a sideways shift--
you send some code
to your teammate,
but you don't send
it to the, server
you want to make sure you
know what you're doing
and be very careful with it.
So I recommend, if you're using
a distributed source control
system, until you're really
comfortable with what's
going on there, that
you mostly treat it
like a standard server based
system until you're really--
and make sure if you do
any other kinds of cross
submits that you know
what you're doing
and you think about
it a little bit.
The cool thing
about these systems,
though, is that,
if I make a change
and I send it to my
teammate, and both of us
submit it to the central
server, it actually
keeps track of that.
It says, oh, it's
the same change.
I don't need to apply it twice.
It's actually a really
very clever technology.
It's very, very cool
and very powerful,
but like many
powerful technologies
it can be very confusing.
So as I say, start out here, and
if you're feeling really cocky,
go there.
A couple quick rules about this.
They're not going to apply to
you yet, because you're not yet
writing code in teams, but
the policy is for most teams
never ever, ever
break the build.
And when I say
break the build, I
mean you want it to be the case
that that one canonical copy,
the perfect copy of
your project, anybody
can go to an empty machine,
run a get, get all the files,
hit the Build button
for whatever environment
you're using, and have it
build and work perfectly.
That is the goal.
That's what you always want.
And if you ever submit
something to the server that
makes that impossible,
it's highly likely
that you have just made everyone
else in your team have to wait.
And that's a big
pain because they're
going to be sitting there
wishing they could get work
done, but they did a get to make
sure they could do the merge,
and then all of a sudden they
can't get any work done at all.
So you want to make 100%
sure that you can always,
always, always do that build.
Another thing--
and this is me sort
of stepping aside to my
coding hat-- you should always
have zero errors
and zero warnings
if at all humanly
possible in you project.
A lot of times I see
programmers who are just
starting out who think
that warnings are optional,
and it's true.
Unfortunately, most of
them are kind of optional,
but there's two problems with
leaving them in your build.
Problem number one is
some of them are optional,
but they do in fact
highlight an issue
that you should think about.
And if you leave it there
on the screen and ignore it,
you might be ignoring
an important tool
that'll help you find a bug.
But in the second one, I
think it's even more important
actually-- is that
as soon as you
get used to seeing warnings
in your build every time,
you start ignoring
all the warnings.
So let's say there are five
warnings that pop up in your
build every time you build
it, and this has been
true for a week and a half now.
And you're writing some code
and you add two warnings,
and you don't notice
because there are warnings.
Five to seven, you didn't
notice the difference,
but one of two
warnings that you added
might be really important.
So if you can get
down to zero warnings,
as soon as you had
one morning, it
will instantly hit your
brain, and your brain
will say, oh, wait a minute.
I did something
that the computer
says is a little bit risky.
And in computer
science, you want
to avoid a little bit
risky, because it's
going to come back
and bite you, and I
promise it's easier to fix a bug
10 minutes after you wrote it
than a day after you wrote it.
And a week after you wrote
it, it's even harder.
We in this class won't get
to a year after you wrote it,
but sometime in your
career, you probably will,
and you won't enjoy it.
Avoids bugs the first
time if you can.
So therefore I call
use a check build.
On a team, you might say
to someone sitting next
to you, hey, can you
do a get and build
and make sure I
didn't mess it up?
That's one easy way to
do it, but actually you
don't need to do that.
On all these source
control systems
you can have more than one--
what we call-- workspace.
It might be your local
version of the code.
You can have two
workspaces-- one
where you're doing your work.
You check it all into
the central server.
Second one, you go to
the second workspace.
You pull the code down.
You do a build.
You verify that
everything still works,
and that's a safety way that
you can in a couple minutes
verify that you aren't about
to make the entire team wait
and lose time.
Couple little tips that,
again, you probably
won't need a little
bit, but I'm going
to talk about it very quickly
now so you don't forget.
All these things
I'm talking about
are things you're probably
going to have to look up
the details on how
to do them, but I
want you to at least
have heard the words,
so that when you see
them on the screen,
they'll look familiar to you and
you'll know what you can find.
Ignore unneeded files is
a really powerful thing.
Almost all these systems
can ignore types of files.
For example, if
you're working in C#,
there might be some
object files or whatever,
and you don't want
to check those in.
It doesn't help you
to check them in.
In particular, if you're using
Perforce, checking them in
is actually problematic, because
one of the things that Perforce
does that the other
systems don't do
is Perforce uses
the read only flag
as a way on your local machine
to tell you whether or not
you have a file checked
out for changes.
So if a file is read
only, it's saying
you haven't told me that you're
going to change this file,
so I'm not going to let you.
If you try to do a build on
a bunch of read only files,
your build environment
has two choices.
It can ignore that,
which is kind of scary,
or it can just fail.
So that's kind of annoying,
but more to the point,
there's no reason to check
in these gigantic product
files that are all part of your
build when you could actually
build everything
from the bare source.
The only things you want
to actually check in
are the original source
files for your project,
whether that be art,
audio code, whatever,
but you want to be able to
rebuild the entire thing.
And all the intermediate
files or the final result
files-- generally speaking,
you don't want to check those
into source control, unless
you've got a special build
folder or something.
You want to have
one folder, which
is purely pull down the
project and build it,
and it contains
all the information
necessary to regenerate
everything that you can.
So if you can ignore all
the files that you don't
want to check in, that's good.
This is particularly
a problem with Unity.
You don't want to
check in anything
but the asset folder and
the project settings folder.
There's a bunch of
gigantic folders in Unity
that look important,
and they are important,
but Unity will
regenerate them for you,
and you don't want
to check them in.
And then finally, I talked
about locking before.
Lock you binary files
and your big text
files that don't merge well
just to avoid headaches.
If you don't do that and more
than one person touches that
file, eventually you'll
get in a situation
where you lose your changes
because someone else checked
in something over you.
Similarly with a
merge be careful.
If someone has checked
in a-- even to text file,
and you do get it
down to the server,
and it has to merge with your
changes, and you don't do that,
and you just say, nah,
forget their changes.
Use mine.
That's going to be a
problem, because someone
just loss some work there.
Luckily with source control
you can recover from that,
but it won't be smooth teamwork.
No one will be happy that
you wiped out their changes.
That is the quick
version, and now we're
going to go on to a workshop.
So you should be sitting
near people who used the game
engine that you used.
Hopefully most of you
actually did this thing.
So what we want to do is team
up in pairs with people ideally
who used your engine.
If there's only three of
you who used your engine,
I guess you're a triplet.
And what we want to do
is-- ideally two ways,
but one way will do.
One of you should say,
yes, I've got working code.
It's pretty cool.
Run it.
Show everyone.
See it works.
And then pick a source
control engine of your choice.
I recommend GitHub, because
it's easy to get things set up.
Check in your code, have the
other people check it out,
and see if they can build it.
And then if you succeed at
that, swap and do the other way
around.
Actually, you can do
this simultaneously.
Everyone can start
checking in to new projects
and then pull down.
Well I'll take that as a
cue that I can start talking
a little bit, but not for long.
I promise.
So the next step we want to
do is discuss the game engines
that you did the tutorials for.
You probably did a
little bit of that
already because you've
been hanging out
with people near
you who use them,
but I want you to try
to get into groups
of five to six people.
If you can't, that's fine,
but try to balance it out.
There probably should be about
two groups per game engine.
And talk about what
your experiences
were with the tutorials.
So things like, what was easy?
What was hard?
What was more difficult
than you expected?
Compare your experiences on
different operating systems
if you happen to
have that experience.
Compare your experiences if
you used different tutorials
or the same tutorial,
but basically I
want you to get an idea of
what other people's experiences
we're like compared to your own.
And the main reason
for this is that you
want to figure out
something a little bit more
about your game engine,
because after this, we're
going to shuffle and
get into groups where
we've mixed up the game engine.
So for example, if
you used HaxeFlixel,
you'll be in a
group with someone
who used Flixel and
someone who used Unity,
and you want to compare
and contrast those engines.
And so think of this
first discussion as a way
to figure out how to talk
about your game engine
and maybe learn more about other
people's experiences with it.
So I believe that we're
already seated mostly
near each other in
the game engines.
I think that's all I
need to say really.
So split up into groups of five
or six in your game engine,
and if you need help
with that, we'll help.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW GRANT: 15.
15 minutes of that,
and then we'll
swap in to do multiple-- we'll
help you with that part, too.
PHILIP TAN: Your
attention, please.
May I have your
So I think a lot of you-- I
see quite a few groups are
winding down on their discussion
within the same game engine.
Now what we're going to do
is ask you to gather back
in your original brainstorming
groups, which is probably
going to be pretty close to
the combination of the teams
that you are currently in.
So remember when we did
brainstorming on Monday?
Those people?
You are going to
gather with them,
and hopefully
you're going to get
a good spread of
different game engines
within that discussion group.
And what we want you to do
is share your experience
having used that game engine.
First, take a quick survey
around of which game
engines are being
represented, have a talk so
that you know which game
engines you're discussing.
Then talk about
what you found good,
what you found terrible
about those game engines,
and what you recommend it for.
OK?
PROFESSOR: As a primary
motivator for this,
project two starts
next Monday, and you're
going to choose an engine
and make a game in it.
And you're going to be committed
to that engine for about 2
and 1/2 weeks.
So that's the whole reason why
we're talking about this stuff.
ANDREW GRANT: This might
not need to be said,
but if half of you used one
game engine, do some swapping.
I would like to see we can
put a final couple of details
as to what we discovered here.
If you were to try to describe
the experience of Haxe
in a sentence like
thumbs up, thumbs down,
what was the hardest thing?
Anybody?
Please?
AUDIENCE: There weren't a
lot of resources out there
[? for it. ?]
ANDREW GRANT: Not
a lot of resources.
So you couldn't find help
me when you got stuck?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's pretty [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW GRANT: OK, I've heard
that the install process is
painful.
Let's see.
What else have I heard?
Anything else?
Anything to recommend it?
AUDIENCE: Once you got it
up and running, it was easy.
ANDREW GRANT: Once you got it
up and running it was easy.
All right, cool.
AUDIENCE: Personally
I was on a Mac,
and I found the
installation really simple.
It was just a couple
of [INAUDIBLE] calls,
and it seemed like it was
really useful for a simple game.
I'm not sure how [INAUDIBLE]
will get when we were trying
[INAUDIBLE], but for getting a
very simple game running fast,
it's nice.
ANDREW GRANT: So it sounds
like there's some mixed
experience on the install.
Mac may be the difference.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: I was also on a
Mac, and once I figured out
how to install on a Mac,
it was extremely simple,
but the thing was the
tutorial was just for Windows.
Install Flash [INAUDIBLE].
Do this.
Do that.
I was like, OK. [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW GRANT: So the
main thing I've heard
then is the support is limited.
The install may or may not be
hard, but if you get stuck,
the support isn't going to
help you through it, at least
in that experience.
The main reason why I think
HaxeFlixel might be interesting
is because I actually know
that Flixel is interesting,
but you guys may have a
different opinion on that.
So Flixel.
Any other big picture
takeaway for Flixel?
You're all going to
disagree with me now, which
is fine, but say something.
AUDIENCE: I think it's
support is also limited.
ANDREW GRANT: OK.
And one of problems
I've seen in Flixel
is that it, in fact, has evolved
over about five or six years
now.
And so if you look
for a bug in Flixel
and try to figure out
what was going wrong,
it'll say, well, in Flixel
4, you want to do this.
It does end up being a
little bit more complicated
there, too.
So in addition to
there not being
as much support as there
is for, say, Unity,
it's fragmented support.
And then of course, Flash
is one of those technologies
that people are
considering to be aging.
I will say, however, that in
my experience for 2D stuff,
Flixel is really, really easy
to pick up once you get going,
and it can really do the
2D stuff pretty well.
On the other hand, we have a
new contender there, Phaser,
which I heard the [? trial ?]
was really, really
good for Phaser.
Does anyone have any
takeaway on Phaser?
The trial was good.
It handled 2D stuff pretty well.
We haven't gone in
depth on collisions.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] it
was definitely good for 2D.
It's very intuitive, and it's
all written in JavaScript,
so not too complicated.
[INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW GRANT: Does anybody
know if it supports TypeScript?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW GRANT: It does
support TypeScript.
Did anyone use
TypeScript for Phaser?
No?
Oh, you did?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDREW GRANT: Right, I just
talked to you about that.
In fact, you were able to
use a debugger with Phaser
through Visual Studio, right?
That actually I find
pretty encouraging.
Someone's put some
thought into that.
How about support?
Where there are a lot
of people using Phaser?
Enough that you can get
some help through searches?
Yeah.
OK, cool.
So it sounds like Phaser is
a-- I haven't heard about many
of the HTML5 engines
that I would actually
want to recommend,
but it sounds like
so for your
experiences with Phaser
have been pretty positive,
which is pretty cool.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about Phaser.
What about the install process?
Any thoughts on that?
[INAUDIBLE] files could just
[? be ?] [INAUDIBLE] HTML
[INAUDIBLE] scripts.
ANDREW GRANT: So you just
copied it in, and it works?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so Phaser has
version control pretty much
[INAUDIBLE] because you have
to pull everything from Git.
The second tutorial of
making the game was great,
but as a couple of us
noticed, the first tutorial
had installation-- like
setting up a web server
and then choosing your ID was
a little bit more obfuscated.
It's like, why are
they telling us
to do these things [INAUDIBLE]?
ANDREW GRANT: Oh, right.
Right.
Yeah, because I do
think that-- there
was somebody said if
you set up a web server,
this is how I would do it.
And I think the answer is
there are easier ways to do it
than they have
suggested, especially
if you're an MIT student.
You can copy it to
your web locker,
and whoa, you've installed
it-- is a fine way to do it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
With the TypeScript installation
it enables to [INAUDIBLE]
copy paste in [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW GRANT: Cool.
All right, and then I split
Unity into concentrate on 2D,
concentrate on 3D, but
fundamentally there
is a difference between those
two-- that Unity pretty much--
and I heard someone even saying
that Unity is designed for 3D,
and they've kind of pasted
2D on top of it, which
I think is an accurate criticism
about usability on that.
Has anyone experienced
the-- trying to use the 2D,
was that a problem?
Are you going to still need to
think in 3D to make it work?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the other
thing was the initial learning
curve was pretty-- took a
while to get something simple
started.
[? But I feel ?] like
there's a lot of potential
making more complex 2D stuff.
ANDREW GRANT: Sure.
AUDIENCE: It definitely
doesn't feel lacking.
It's like Photoshop in
the sense that there's
all these features, and you
maybe not even 10% of them,
but they're there
if you need them,
which may or may
not be a good thing,
because that can be very
intimidating and sort
of hard to work.
ANDREW GRANT: Sure.
I agree with that 100%.
There's too much there, perhaps.
If you're trying to
do a quick project,
you might be tempted to
use more than you should.
Also [INAUDIBLE] some things
get lost in the features.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, in
some of the videos
they demonstrate
how you can actually
have 3D objects in
the 2D environment
when you're developing
2D games, which I
guess they were excited about.
And they were just like, hey,
you can do this cool thing,
but I think it has the opposite
effect in that it intimidates
people.
There's a lot of options that
were built originally for 3D,
and looking through
menus and looking
through all drop down
things, most of them
are things you can'
touch or you can't
use, because they're
meant for 3D,
and there's no way you can
restrict the UI to be only 2D.
So I feel like
they should instead
make it into a standalone
Unity 2D software, which
would be easier.
ANDREW GRANT: I understand
why they don't turn it
into standalone
Unity 2D software,
but I think your
point is well taken.
I think that it would
help with their uptake
if they were to try to
limit their feature set,
oddly enough.
This is not the first time
this has happened actually.
Way back when there was Torque,
which is a 3D game engine.
It was really cheap indie--
one of the first indie game
engines for like $100
for use it all you want.
And they started with their
big fancy Torque 3D package,
and everyone said,
wow, this is awesome.
And a bunch of people bought it,
and they never made any games,
because 3D is, as
we've mentioned,
more than three
times as hard as 2D,
and so they came out with Torque
2D, and that did a lot better.
Again, because developers--
3D is an extra hurdle
to jump over, and when
all the developers have
to deal with a short
time frame, and that 3D
can get in your way.
So I think the takeaway
for me on Unity
is basically the same,
which is it's a lot.
You can do a lot with it, but
it's got a learning curve.
It's going to be a little
bit harder for you,
so you might want to think
twice about doing that,
especially if
you're concentrating
on a 2D game, which you probably
should be doing, if you can,
this semester.
Unity also has a
couple things that
are a little bit different.
I think mostly
Flixel certainly--
and sounds like Phaser has
a little Flixel blood in it.
They're both designed for 2D.
Very simple, straightforward
implementations
in an object
oriented kind of way.
Unity has this crazy
component system
where you've got one
object, but you staple
anything you want to to it.
And it's really,
really powerful,
but also it takes a while
to your brain around it.
So long story short, I
would say that, if you
can do what you want
to do without taking
on a big engine like
Unity, I kind of recommend
that, but obviously
if you need to do it
and will kind of-- the reason
[INAUDIBLE] if you tell us
that you do need to do it,
but if you do need to do,
it's worth
considering, because I
think it is a very powerful
and useful friendly engine.
AUDIENCE: Which one
has [? faster ?]
development cycles?
ANDREW GRANT: Good
question, but I'm only
going to guess at this point
in our experience we have not
used Phaser in a class before.
I know Flixel is
faster than Unity.
It sounds like from the
feedback we're getting here
that Phaser might
be a good contender,
so I would recommend
in project two
you might want to take a
look at those two engines
as your first go to
things and check it out,
because there's
not good options.
I would go there first, though,
rather than going straight
to Unity, unless
you've got a team that
really wants to take it on.
AUDIENCE: Are we limited
to these options [? that ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW GRANT: Yes, you're
limited to these options.
So let's see.
I think our next step
then is something else.
PROFESSOR: Yes, it is.
So congratulations.
You've gotten through the
first 2/3 of class today.
[APPLAUSE]
Yay.
And that was our
gaming tutorial,
so keep all of these
thoughts in mind
as we start up
project two next week.
The remainder of
class is going to be
devoted to finishing
up project-- or doing
more work on project one.
We're going to do two
activities that we mentioned
at the beginning of class.
We're going to start
off with play test.
So if you have something
testable, great.
You're ahead of the game.
If you don't have
something testable,
we're going to give you
a little bit of time
to get you to
something testable.
What do we mean by testable?
It means somebody
else that is not
on your team with a
little bit of guidance
by somebody on the team can
make things happen in the game.
That gives you feedback
that says that was cool.
That's what we were going
for or that's really broken.
That's awful.
Let's not go that direction.
That's all we're asking for
you to do for class today.
So at 3 o'clock, we are
going to start the play test.
It is 2:47 PM right now.
Ignore that first part.
Basically what we're going to
do is set up your in your teams.
Every team should
have their game set up
and ready to play at 3 o'clock.
The team that is
closest to them--
you're going to first
one team is going
to play the other team's game.
You can have 15 minutes
to do that and then swap.
If you followed project
one's examples correctly
and you have a five
minute game play
game, so your game can be
played in five minutes or less,
you can get three
tests done today.
Awesome.
But if you only get
one or two, that's OK.
You've got the whole weekend
to finish up on that, too.
So come back into this room 3
o'clock with your game set up,
and we'll start the play test.
Does everybody have
a playable game?
Yes?
Thumbs up if you're ready to go.
OK.
All right, so we are not
just playing our games.
We are play testing
our games, and we
are following the
Wizard of Oz method
that Philip mentioned on Monday.
By that what we mean
is all of your games
probably have some
kind of computer
that's doing
something in the game
that the player is
interacting with the computer.
What that means is there is
some constrained communication
between the computer
and the player.
This is a time where
you want to think
about what are the things
that the player knows
versus what are the things
that the computer is doing.
There's going to be a little bit
of a difference going on there.
Don't let the player
know what the computer
is thinking, unless it's
actually part of the game.
If you could imagine the
computer saying here's
a screen with an icon on it
that says some stuff, that's
something the player knows.
If it's just some
calculation going
on in the background, that is
not something the player knows.
So just think about it that
way when you're doing this.
So how many teams do
we have over here?
One, four?
OK, so pair.
How many teams do
we have in here.
One, two, three,
four, five, six.
Is that right?
So pair to your
closest, and then pair.
And how many teams over here?
One, two-- is that three total?
All right, instructors
will test the back one.
So you have 15 minutes
to play one game.
I'm going to come back in at
3:15 PM and tell you to switch.
SARA VERILLI: OK,
so we're going to do
the shift from the
very fun play testing
and working on games to talking
a little bit about project
management.
And as he said, we're
trying to get the project
management in it bit by bit.
Hopefully the point at which
it becomes helpful in each
of your projects.
So the first thing we're
going to talk about here
is vision statements.
Why are we talking
about vision statements?
I'd rather be play testing
someone else's game.
The very short answer is
because it's good for you
and because it's good
for your project.
The longer answer is because
a vision statement is really
one of the shortest
and simplest ways
to make sure that you,
the people on your team,
and the person you are making
the game for-- assuming you are
making the game for a client,
or an instructor or someone else
who might be interested in
it-- are all on the same page
and understand that understand
what they expect to get
at the end of the project.
It can't guarantee
that you all believe
you're getting the
same thing, but you
can get started by
being on the same page.
Another very common early
design document for games
is the design doc.
Has anybody here heard of
design documents, I assume?
Yeah.
Do you know what they are?
Does anyone not know what I
mean when I say a design doc?
OK, traditionally--
and this is actually
going further and further
back into the history
of game development,
for which I am thankful.
Traditionally, a game
design doc was a document,
usually a big word page
that might occasionally
get printed out, that
pretty must described
the game from start to finish--
everything that was going
to happen in it, all the
mechanics, all the characters,
all the stories, all the
interactions, everything
that's going to happen.
It was traditionally
a very big, long file
that, A, either someone spent
a lot of time maintaining
and nobody be spent
any time reading,
or, B, nobody spent
any time maintaining
and nobody spent
any time reading.
So it was not what I would
call a very useful investment
of time, but a lot of time
tended to get invested in it.
So you may ask, why?
At least partially
because people feel better
when things are written down.
They'd like to have a place
they can go to look at to say,
am I doing what I think
we're supposed to be doing?
I'd like to go
check the documents
and see if that's true.
Unfortunately, a
really long document
that tries to detail
everything is not the right way
to try and do this on a game.
Games change too fast.
And the thing you're
trying to get to,
the end product of the
game, is not written.
It's not something that's going
to be something you look at.
It's something that
happens in action.
So our proposed substitute--
and if someone comes up
with a better solution,
I would love to hear it,
because vision statements are
also not the perfect thing.
They're just better than
anything else I've seen.
Our solution to this
is a vision statement.
We tend to think that,
in between a prototype,
and a vision statement,
and really good project
communication, that's about--
and really good communication
on your project, that's most
of the design documentation
you need.
All right, so we're going to
talk about vision statements,
and then we're
going to make one.
So there you go.
I forgot that I included
the animation on the slide.
I did not time it right.
Oh well.
That's what I get for
trying to be fancy.
So if a vision
statement is going
to define the project-- so
vision statements defines
the project-- or the game if
it's for a game-- for the team,
for the client,
and its investors.
What do you think it ought
to include to do that?
I see my chalk boards
have already been used,
and the chalk has been hidden.
There it is.
All right, any ideas?
Any suggestions?
What would you like to
have in such a document?
You're the ones using it.
AUDIENCE: Goals.
[? Scope. ?]
SARA VERILLI: Goals.
Scope.
I heard ideas.
What kind of ideas?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SARA VERILLI: The game.
AUDIENCE: Goals, ideas.
SARA VERILLI: Goals,
ideas, the game.
So I've got goals.
I've got ideas.
I've got scope.
I heard game.
AUDIENCE: Theme.
SARA VERILLI: Theme.
Theme, OK.
Theme, that sounds like
a really good idea.
AUDIENCE: Core mechanics.
SARA VERILLI: Core
mechanics, yeah.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: The story
if there is one.
SARA VERILLI: Story.
AUDIENCE: The audience.
SARA VERILLI: Audience.
Anything else you
think you really need?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
characters.
SARA VERILLI: Characters.
I think this is actually
pretty darn good list.
The tricky part with
a vision statement
is trying to get most of
that in on one page or less.
The other thing that
you vision statement
may want to include that is
less relevant to the vision
part of the statement and
more relevant to the team
is, who's working on the game?
What's the name of the game?
What is each person
on the team going
to contribute to the
game, so that the vision
statement becomes both a
contract about what the game is
going to be and what the team
is going to do to get it done.
So surprise, surprise.
We actually have
a format for this.
Actually, we have
two different formats
to help you get all of these
things crammed in on one page
and hopefully express it well
enough that you will understand
and be able to use it.
We have what we call the back
of the box vision statement
and a high level design
doc, and you guys
are welcome to choose to
use either one of those two
frameworks.
They're up on Stellar.
They can be downloaded, and
once I finish talking at you,
I will pull them up so you
can see them up on the screen
and actually see what
the files look like.
The idea behind the back
of the box vision statement
is it takes a marketing
pitch approach.
Instead of actually
stating here's the goals,
here's the theme, here's
the core mechanic,
here's the scope, the
team comes together
and tries to find three,
or four, or five bullet
points that would go on
the back of the box that
capture those ideas
within the bullet points.
You've all seen
the box-- OK, maybe
you haven't seen the
back of a game box
these days because half the
games are being so downloaded
from Steam, but they still have
the little marketing pitches
where it says fire
38 different guns,
form teams with your
friends and back stab them.
That sort of thing.
[LAUGHTER]
But if that is the way your team
thinks and your team envisions
the game back, that
can be a very good way
to formulate and encapsulate
all of those ideas,
especially if you
can really drill down
to what are the four things
you want people to say
about your game, and
then every time you make
a decision about your game,
every time you add a mechanic,
every time you add a story,
a character, a setting,
you make a change of the way
the game works, you can go back.
Read those four or five
bullet points and say,
is this change actually
enhancing and working
with that pitch?
And if it is, it's
probably a good change.
And if it isn't, it
probably is a bad change.
It gives you something
to really have
a core of your game around.
Some people don't
think like that.
Some people don't think in
terms of marketing pitches.
They'd much rather have a better
spelled out this is my goal.
This is the setting.
This is the mechanics.
A high level design doc is
the solution for those people,
and in it, it asks for a
goal statement for your game
as a short paragraph written
out, rather than as pitch.
It's got a little less bang,
but it is often more precise,
and both of them are
equally effective.
What really depends
on is which one
resonates with the team,
which one the team thinks
works well for them.
That's why we have both of them.
They're really covering
the same information.
You don't save anything
by choosing one format
over the other.
It's just how are
you presenting it
to yourself and to your team.
Both documents also ask for
a little bit of game play.
A risk assessment-- what are
the big risks on your game?
They may be related
to your team.
Hey, we're trying an engine
we never tried before.
We may not be able
to get to run.
It may be related
to the game play.
We are going to try and do
a mechanic no one has ever
managed to do before.
Whatever your big risk is.
Just one or two sentences of it.
And then some space
for your team members
to put in your names,
what they're going to do,
stuff like that.
It's really pretty simple.
And the next step is, in
fact, to do exactly that.
So as a three person
team, go ahead
and decide which format
you're going to use.
Create your vision document.
Decide who's going to
upload it for Monday.
Make sure you've got
people's names on it
so we know who did what, because
if we're only uploading one
document, that means
we're only getting
one document for every
three people in class,
and we would like to
give credit to everyone
for having worked on them.
And you're going to have until
the end of class, so about
20 minutes.
Let me see if I can find where
Rick has hidden the forms.
Are they--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, sorry.
Don't look at my calendar.
SARA VERILLI: I'm not
looking at your calendar.
Oh no.
I am looking at your calendar.
I'm sorry.
I'm not looking at the calendar.
You're looking at the calendar.
I'm sorry.
PROFESSOR: I don't know how
well they're going to fit.
SARA VERILLI: Well, we'll
do them one at a time.
We'll just do them
one at a time.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
kind of look.
AUDIENCE: To clarify, the
upload comes before Monday.
Not before the end
of class, right?
SARA VERILLI: Yeah.
Yeah, the upload--
the turn in date
is for Monday, before the
start of class on Monday.
And the main thing is
you're not actually
writing division doc for
the prototype you just made.
The prototype you
made is the core--
is the core mechanics for the
game you envision being made
with it for project two, OK?
So this is your vision document,
your sort of pitchy document,
for project two-- with
the game that will
be made for project two, OK?
All right, anyway so here's
the high level design document.
I think that there's both an
RTF format and a Word format
up there.
When you upload them, we
much prefer it to be in PDF.
That way easy for us to read.
I love trying to do this
while not being able to see
what I'm doing on the screen.
PROFESSOR: Look on Stellar.
SARA VERILLI: I like mice.
I much prefer mice.
I hate touch pads.
PROFESSOR: I also make
mine kind of wonky.
SARA VERILLI: Oh, thanks.
PROFESSOR: You're
trying to scroll.
SARA VERILLI: Thanks.
OK, yeah, I'm trying to scroll.
So this is basically the
high level design doc,
and what it's got-- vision,
breakdown, major game play
concepts, 30 seconds of game
play, and then your risks,
and the team responsibility
and breakdown.
Let's go ahead and jump
over to the vision document.
And here's the
vision statement one.
Basically all of
that-- goal, and stuff
needs be contained in your
back of the box advertisement.
And then the rest of it
is pretty much the same.
Any questions?
OK, if there's no questions, go.
PROFESSOR: OK, before
you leave, just
want to make sure
we all understand
what is due tomorrow,
because all of our projects
are pretty complex.
AUDIENCE: Tomorrow?
PROFESSOR: Monday.
Monday.
Thank you.
You're awake.
So for project one on
Monday before class
starts-- so before 1:00
PM-- turn into Stellar
the following three things.
An individual post
mortem-- so this
is a one page write up of
your experiences working
on this project.
The specifications are in
that project one assignment.
That's so we can know what
you got out of this project.
The design change log.
You made some changes today.
So on your change log,
you should at least
have one entry on
it at the end today.
Now you've got two
entries on it hopefully.
Test your game this weekend.
Make some changes to the
prototype this weekend.
Add them to the change log.
Only one per team.
So appoint one person to
submit all the team documents,
submit it, make sure all
of your names are on it.
The vision document,
which you've just
been working on-- one per team.
And again, it's a little
weird for project one
because you're
talking about what it
would be like for project two.
So under team roles
and responsibilities,
project two is a
six person project.
If you have an idea of what
are the complex things that
are going to be
needed for project two
that those mystery three
people would be working on,
put them down-- or in
your case, four people.
So imagine that you are working
on this project for project
two.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so for the
vision statement things,
are we-- for the vision
documents [INAUDIBLE] write.
PROFESSOR: Can you
hold on one second?
I can't hear.
AUDIENCE: For the vision
document that we have to hand
in on Monday, are
we assuming that--
for the team
responsibility break down,
are we assuming that
we'll be working on this--
PROFESSOR: Assume you are
working on this as-- yes.
AUDIENCE: Splitting up
responsibility [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly right.
Now, what we're doing
in class-- one minute
to pitch your game as a
project two contender.
You're going to come up here and
just give us a quick elevator
pitch.
What is the game?
Why is the game exciting?
How does the game do
what it's going to do?
Based on this vision document.
And then you're going to
give us a demonstration
of the prototype,
and that's actually
going to happen in this
big-- basically how
we did play testing today.
You'll be
demonstrating the game,
and more people will play your
game so that we can figure out
which games we want to work on.
Question there and
then question there.
AUDIENCE: So does it
have to be [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Has to be paper.
This project one is paper.
Project one is non-digital.
AUDIENCE: So when do we know
which projects everybody is
going to be working on.
PROFESSOR: By the end of class
on Monday, all of the teams
will be formed for project two.
So project two-- again,
it's a single player game,
project two.
Some of you have made
multiplayer games.
That's OK.
Imagine what the game is going
to be like for a single player.
Are those other players AI?
Make them AI, but project
two [? as a ?] digital game
is only a single player game.
Do not turn in a multiplayer
game for project two.
For project four, we're going
to relax that, but for two
and three, just
to make sure we're
getting some games in here
let's make them single player.
Again, five minutes
of game play.
Again, planning for randomness.
Is your game right now-- if
project one doesn't quite
fit that planning for
randomness theme, that's OK.
In your vision document, what
would you do for project two
to beef that up to make
that really pop out.
And again, project
two-- those four engines
that we worked on today.
Not photon, Phaser.
I miswrote that.
Those are the game engines
we're working for project two.
So I kept you a little too late.
Sorry.
If you want to keep
working in the room,
I don't think anybody
has it afterwards,
so feel free to work.
Feel free to leave.